[Musique]
au mois de mai c'est à l'est située à
l'arrière de la mairie de bras-panon
sont généralement plein malgré le
contexte les partenaires du monde
agricole ont voulu féliciter
l'excellence des éleveurs à travers huit
catégories
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
treize prix ont été remis et pour ces
éleveurs mobilisés à tous les instants
ça compte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ben on connaît le travail parfois je
suis malheureusement mais sont plus
payés par ben saoud lina deux fois à ben
c'est faux travaille tous les jours les
adieux dimanche point de jeu après une
semaine pour rien
donc c'est au sacrifice vie mais à la
fin on le récompense il a voulu faire
une photo des coûts la sortie comme
monsieur là c'est qui ça c'est mon papy
sains à bas parce que les représente
beaucoup moins m'a toujours grandi avec
lui noodles animaux ensemble mais j'ai
dû me montrer de quoi mieux capable
aussi beaucoup une histoire de famille
oui c'est une histoire famille avait
obligé ça nous sommes pas animaux prend
plaisir à les fouilles à mlle ça fait
vraiment des besoins de solutions au
quotidien pour ces travailleurs qui
alimentent notre population
ainsi une cellule d'accompagnement
spécifiques existent au département de
quoi comprendre les attentes et
répondent au plus vite
département et chef de file de la
politique agricole à la réunion en plus
elle est également autorité de gestion
pour le faire taire donc il revenait de
droit au département d'attribuer à un
prix comme ça se passe depuis plusieurs
années d'ailleurs et en plus a fortiori
dans le contexte sanitaire où les
éleveurs ont besoin de se sentir de
savoir pour les lâche pas ces hommes et
ces femmes pas forcément habitué d'être
sous les feux des projecteurs n'ont
cette année pas leur foire agricole de
bras-panon à toutes ces performances ont
quantifié par la chambre d'agriculture
notamment un donc les techniciens et un
suivi suivi de performances dans les
élevages que ce soit par exemple bovins
viande bovins et les porcins ou lâchant
maux quotidiens et aux côtés des
agriculteurs pour les accompagner là
dessus
la chambre dispose d'un de données très
importantes assure la l'évolution des
cheptels à la reno l'évolution de la
croissance des cheptels sur la génétique
des cheptels donc c'est un travail de
fond qu'il faut faire ce travail permet
demain de nous prémunit à de nouvelles
catastrophes sanitaires dans le monde
animal mais aussi d'avoir une
traçabilité irréprochable de ce qui est
mis dans l'assiette du consommateur
réunionnais les mains pleines et le
sourire aux lèvres parce que la vie
continue
il faut vite rentrer au chant pour
s'occuper du bétail
[Musique]